on the mound for the mariners a guy that
seattle went out and got at the trade
deadline because in part of his
experience it's tyler anderson 31 year
old veteran southpaw
the only mariners pitcher gooby to have
started a post-season game in his career
he had a lot of fastballs from anderson
two seamer four seamer cutter change up
curveball my go-to have success against
him today is drive that change up up for
power he's giving up ten home runs
versus change up and back up the middle
with his fastballs don't get in that
pull mode up the middle success here it
is game number
162 on the season and one of the most
exciting games that's going to be played
in the history of this franchise the
mayor who's trying to keep this magic
going that's well hit out to right and
he's done it ohtani leads off the game
with a homer
yes what a way to get rbi number 100 of
the season
time show me the money with a swing
there scott service all as you can think
is why did we pitch to him ends up
getting a cutter 86 miles an hour and
that is center cut here's phil gosling
the pitch on the way fastball swung
online drive left field for a base head
up for the ball as dylan moore gets to
throw into second so gosling jumping on
the first pitch from tyler trying to
regroup in a hurry
pick off play goes bad
gosselin's to get all the way to third a
couple of self-inflicted wounds by the
mariners and the angels are knocking on
the door of a second run homer single
error and two infield pop-ups and now
jack mayfield who's two for eight in the
first two games of the series mayfield
grounds it to the shortstop hole
crawford with a great play throw to
first not in time
gosselin scores two nothing angels he is
on the bag as the ball starts to get
into the glove of ty france yeah no
challenge for scott i think the right
call was made on the field however
they could not have been any closer
without being a tie outfield straight
away anderson ready high leg kick 3-2
swung on fly ball left field dylan moore
camps underneath now he comes in a few
steps he's there and that's going to
retire the side with the angels getting
two runs here in the top of the first
inning on three hits one air and one man
left on we head to the bottom of the
first ideal circumstances for reed
detmers to make his final assignment of
his rookie year
last year's first round draft selection
by the angels making his fifth career
start here this afternoon
with important ramifications on the line
for the opponent
two-nothing lead for him as he settles
in and he strikes out crawford looking
and crawford knew it he took that pitch
he's out looking one away
angel's lefty's pitch and this is
bounced on the right side should be an
easy play fletcher has it throws him out
and the inning is over so seattle will
leave a couple runners on base they
didn't have any hits in the inning or a
couple of walks but detmer's pitches out
of a little bit of trouble in the first
second is coming up two-nothing angels
fletch now had a two-for-four game
yesterday that ended an 0 for 32 stretch
fletch with a fair ball into the left
field corner three-nothing angels as
rojas scores easily
and this ball went right over the bag at
third a fair ball and the rbi double for
david fletcher and if i'm a betting man
i don't think tyler anderson is going to
be real long for this afternoon here's
the next pitch
and he lifts this one in the air into
left center field this will be deep
enough to get a run in making the catch
out there is more tagging in coming in
and scoring easily will be david
fletcher it's four or nothing angels so
sac fly nice job by the halos getting
another run two and two so far
in the first two innings and that's it
for the seattle starter the look in by
dentmers here's the pitch on the way to
celtic swinging a line drive base into
the right field here comes trends on the
score jared kellnick jumps on a pitch
from detmer's singles in the right and
the mariners get on the board fans on
their feet here it's t-mobile park
and it's now the angels four and the
mariners won jared kelneck with his 43rd
rbi of the season and the fans are right
back in it thanks to jared's base hit
need a two-half knock here from jp
crawford took a call third strike on a
one-two pitch leading off the home first
broken back up to the middle
here comes jk he's gonna score easily
here come the mariners pick a little
here pick a little there
get on the board get back in it for two
angels rbi for j.p crawford is 53rd
walsh picked up an rbi his last time
upset fly swings at that one and drills
a ball deep down the right side it's out
of here
second night in a row that walsh has hit
one out against seattle that is a
two-run shot and that is a 6-2 angels
lead rick that was hit so hard i was
wondering in flight if that would hit
the ribbon board
in right field it came down shy of it
but that was crushed
would love to cash in on this
opportunity with two honored story
position and two outs myers looks in
ready the stretch and the one one on the
way to ty swaying in a fly ball into
shallow right field down the line on the
run rojas and foul brown he's there
reaches out and he makes the catch
and that will end the inning the
mariners leave two runners stranded in
scoring position we go to the top of the
fifth here's fletch with two gone again
lagarre is aboard and the one one pit
swung on and a fly ball into shallow
left field down the line crawford racing
out going out reaches out and can't get
to it it's going to drop in a fair ball
lagarris will score ronnie's second
ending for third is fletcher the throw
to third not in time
a blue triple down the left field line
dylan moore was shaded out toward left
center field jp crawford had a long way
to go he tried to make a bare-handed
catch down that left field line he fires
swinging a ground ball chopping up the
middle crawford dives for it gets it
flicks it out of his glove toro has the
out at second base they get one that's
suzuki a magic trick by jp crawford
we're getting used to that that was
brilliant showing plenty of range gold
glove winner last year we're going to
have another one this year
lorenz at third raleigh at second
frielly at first top of the order j.p
crawford crowd on its feet
brown ball oh and boots
they still get the out a run does score
that was a taylor made double play and
not executed by fletcher
one does score on the play raleigh the
third and here comes scott service out
of the duck out and he's going to take
kyle seeger off the field right now for
a final salute
scott service is going to make a change
right here and this is all for kyle
seeger this is all for number 15.
and seeger waving at kyle come on kyle
standing ovation from 44 000 plus here
at t-mobile park and this may be the
final time we see one of the
truly great professionals one of the
truly great mariners
in this uniform he comes out of the
dugout and takes the bag from head
groundskeeper tim wilson he holds third
base above him
shows it to the crowd and now the 2021
baseball season
boils down to maybe just one more pitch
here's the pitch on the way in a swing
and a missed by henniger for strike
three
and the magic carpet ride of a 20-21
season comes to a final close the
curtain comes down on one of the most
remarkable seasons i have ever seen here
in seattle
these guys
against all odds defied the odds and
took it to the final inning
of the final game of the regular season